Versailles a fêté ce dimanche son
médaillé olympique Thomas Barou le
sportif de 29 ans qui a décroché l'or
sur le 400 barreurs cet été à Rio s'est
vu réserver un accueil digne d'une
rockstar en compagnie de ses coéquipiers
Tibo Collard et Guillaume Renault sur le
grand canal pour l'occasion une grande
armada gigantesque défilé de bateau étit
organiser pour le champion du Cercle
Nautique l'équipage de l'équipe de
France a pu ramer devant tous les
membres du club c'est sûr que le fait
que les personnes se déplacent pour
venir nous voir et fêter cette médaille
avec nous c'est bah c'est ce qui donne
tout son sens à cette médaille
finalement parce que c'est au-delà d'une
réussite personnelle c'est aussi un
grand moment de partage donc c'est sûr
que c'est ce qui donne tout son sens à
la médaille cet été Harot Thomas Barou
qui est devenu le premier versaillis à
revenir médailler au jeu pour
récompenser cette performance le maire
de la commune François de Maier lui a
remis la médaille de la ville Thomas
c'est un champion olympique c'est bien
le seul qu'on est sur versill
aujourd'hui on en est très fier puis
Thomas incarne très bien les valeurs du
sport c'est quelqu'un très généreux dans
son club très apprécié par tout le monde
et qui est resté tout à fait humble
malgré ses résultats exceptionnel la
matinée s'est terminée par une séance de
dédicace la centaine de fans présents a
pu parler avec le champion versaillais
et repartir avec des autographes sur des
posters c'est super on est très fier
enfin c'est le club de Versailles qui
est qui est à l'honneur euh à la fois le
club la ville enfin c'est on est très
fier d'eux je vais faire petites photos
quand même puis euh ouais c'est just de
leur montrer qu'on est là pour les
soutenir quoi le chapitre Rio se referme
pour Thomas Barou prochain objectif les
championnats de France programmé
mi-avril 2017 le versaillis tentera une
nouvelle fois de rentrer un peu plus
dans la légende de la ville en
remportant une médaille pendant la
compétition